their comfortable existence on the lush
meadows of cayenne Beldon near Grenoble
is about to come to an end
these sheep are rather unusual they're
about to start school
they've already been enrolled all the
paperwork's been submitted down to their
birth certificates is this a joke Takaya
lava and the other parents in town it's
serious business I spoke to Michelle at
the peony festival I know him and know
he's a shepherd so I went up to him and
asked him if he could help save our
children's class at school France's
national school administration wants to
close the class at the local elementary
screen the students were to be assigned
to other classrooms to stop that the
class needed new students even if these
aren't all that interested in book
learning I'm glad to help the community
it's the exact same story with the Sheep
staple for 300 sheep won't fit 500
that's too many and then the Sheep
suffer a school is pretty much the same
15 children the class works well but 35
is a whole different story much to the
joy of their new classmates Michelle
hurted his flock into town then they
were registered for the coming school
year which will start in September
the Lambs just showed up at school and
we were allowed to pet them although the
class was short only five students the
authorities told the school it would be
disbanded with no warning the parents
are still dismayed the children are just
numbers to them we're treated like sheep
so we're using humor to protest no one
wants this so we can't just resign
ourselves to it we have to fight back
the mayor supports their protest a few
years ago the Ministry of Education told
him to build an annex at the school and
now they want to eliminate a class he
says that's absurd the parents have the
support of the municipal council it's an
intelligent alliance so far the parents
are trying to protest in humorous ways
but they could also take more radical
measures the position to say cala
occupying the school occupying the
school the school doesn't want to
comment on the protest everyone's
presenting a united front they believe
the authorities haven't grasped yet that
this is about more than a single class
at school rural france is being
neglected in france if you live in a
rural area you're at a disadvantage
it's called territorial discrimination
the next larger city is pretty far away
but they still wanted to shut down our
bus route and now they want to close the
class at school
Bruce McNall D : famine cuts as part of
their protests the parents have also
posted the school's new extension
building for sale online classroom for
sale very good condition constructed in
2012
no water damage no dry rot good
insulation no asbestos the residents of
Campbell don't say they may live in the
countryside but they're not sheep who
will simply do what they're told